the morning after that historic
indictment Donald Trump is on the attack
we saw this striking image yesterday of
the former president surrounded by his
lawyers in the courtroom where he pled
not guilty to 34 felony counts
prosecutors say the allegations are
linked to hush money payments made to
adult film star Stormy Daniels and two
other people who they say could have
damaged Trump's chances in the 2016
election if there was any speculation
about whether that court appearance
would give Donald Trump pause he put
those questions to rest last night in a
defiant speech at Mar-A-Lago the former
president claimed he's a victim and
targeted the prosecutor and judge in the
case